Уряд Німеччини засуджує арешти мирних демонстрантів
у Москві й непропорційно жорсткі дії російської поліції.
Про це заявили на урядовій прес-конференції.
Окрім того, в Німеччині закликали російську владу
"зберігати розсудливість" і негайно звільнити заарештованих.
- Дотримання принципів ОБСЄ і Ради Європи
має велике значення для демократії, а Росія
взяла на себе зобов'язання дотримуватися
таких принципів, як свобода зібрань та свобода висловлення думок.
Напередодні вересневих регіональних виборів у Росії
уряд Німеччини рішуче закликає до дотримання міжнародних стандартів.
Водночас німецькі експерти особливо зауважують
надзвичайну жорстокість, із якою поліція
діяла щодо демонстрантів. Це робиться навмисно,
впевнені політологи. У такий спосіб чинна влада
ніби демонструє: з неузгодженими в мерії акціями
будуть розбиратися жорстко. Однак,
на думку оглядачів, такі дії призведуть лише
до нових  протестів. Тепер люди виходять на вулицю
вже не через вибори, а щоб виступити проти жорстокості влади.
- В Москві вже вчетверте відбуваються протести
за допуск незалежних кандидатів у Московську міськдуму.
Мені здалося цікавим, що змінився сам зміст протестів.
Якщо спершу вимоги стосувалися насамперед
допуску кандидатів до виборів, то зараз фокус уваги
дедалі більше зміщується саме на жорстокість
і поліцейське свавілля: забирають не лише тих,
хто протестує, а й перехожих, журналістів, науковців.
Найрізноманітніших людей.
Це може кардинально змінити динаміку протестів.
До виборів залишився місяць.
Найближчими вихідними відбудуться нові акції протесту.
Наскільки масовими вони стануть, поки незрозуміло.
Фактично протест обезголовлений, відзначають німецькі експерти.
За їхніми словами, зростає ймовірність того, що
на лідерів акцій чекає кримінальне переслідування.
На лаві підсудних можуть опинитися і співробітники
Фонду боротьби з корупцією, яких Слідчий комітет
звинувачує в відмиванні мільярда рублів.
- Зараз ми бачимо, як Навального атакують
із приводу відмивання грошей. У такий спосіб
московська влада дедалі частіше намагатиметься
нейтралізувати політичних лідерів:
кидати їх за ґрати і виключати з процесу.
Якщо у протестів не буде політичного керівництва,
вони можуть зійти нанівець.
Справа щодо відмивання грошей ФБК може
справді вивести Навального з протестного руху.
Я не виключаю, що саме це і станеться.
Одне з головних запитань, яке ставлять німецькі експерти:
чи зросте протестна активність в Росії після закінчення сезону відпусток.
Остаточно це буде зрозуміло до кінця серпня.